Farberverhinderung muss man fragen.
Extra muss man, wie sieht das Schul aus?
Welche Farbe hat das?
Muss man extra fragen.
Ja, das ist so, vielleicht, aber ich habe so gedacht,
also, haben Sie Probleme? Nein.
Problem ist das nicht, das ist gar kein Problem.
Da ist Schulfarberverhinderung, Farberverhinderung ist gar kein Problem.
Da ist das etwas anders.
Problem ist am meisten entweder hat man Verstoffung oder Deutschwahl.
Das bezeichnet man als Problem.
Und der andere Sache am meisten ist es,
manchmal ab und zu hat man auch Schulfarberverhinderung.
Ja, und dann das wird man nicht als Probleme bezeichnet.
Ja, ja.
Am meisten Patient beschreibt es auch so, ja.
Wenn man dem fragt, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Schul- und
nicht habe ich keine.
Haben Sie Farberverhinderung?
Ja, habe ich doch.
Ich habe gestern Blut im Schul gehabt.
Das ist, was haben das?
Ja, okay.
Nur als Korrektor.
Okay.
Das war Schulverhinderung, schwarze Stuhl.
Ja, ich habe schwarze Stuhl gesehen.
Letzte Woche.
Ja.
Okay.
Und noch zur Fabrielferhinderung hat der Kollegen gefragt,
habe ich nicht.
Doch habe ich gesagt, ich habe so eine warme Gefühl,
habe ich gesagt, so war das.
Ich habe überwiegend das.
Ja, so war das.
Okay, dann ich glaube, wir haben alles gefragt.
Jetzt gehen wir weiter.
Mal mal alles ausgespricht.
Vielleicht wegen der Herr Gundus hat so eine Frage
bzw.
so eine Richtung kardiologisches Problem gestellt.
Kann man so anders anonymisieren?
Haben Sie so eine Belastung Probleme?
Wie ist Ihre Leistung in der letzten Zeit?
Das kann man auch extra fragen.
Wenn man so eine Probleme hat,
so ein Mal Blut auch gesehen,
auch schwarze Stuhlgang gesehen, ein, zwei Mal,
dann kann man ein bisschen tiefer anonymisieren.
Das ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Ob man Leistungmünderung hat oder nicht,
dann kann man in diese Richtung gehen.
Aber hat die Kollegen teilweise schon alles gefragt.
Das kann man noch so ergänzen.
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt als Ansatzgespräch.
Okay, guten Tag Herr Odares.
Ich darf meine neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Gerne.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich möchte heute gerne den 40-Jährigen Patienten
Herr Rahim vorstellen.
Er ist am 1.3.1982 geworden.
Er ist 80 groß und 80 Kilogramm schwer.
Herr Rahim, stellt sich heute
wegen seit gestern bestehender,
starke unerträgliche Oberbauchschmerzen bei uns vor.
Der Patient beschrieb die Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen wurden auf eine Schmerzschkala von 1 bis 10,
mit 7 bis 8 bewertet.
Diese Oberbauchschmerzen
leiden der Patienten seit circa zwei Monaten.
Aber es war nicht wie heute sehr stark.
Heute auch, ja.
Und der Patient gab an, dass die Schmerzen in die rechte Schulter
ausstrahlen würden.
Die Beschwerden, die Schmerzen,
hätten sich nach dem Fethaltigen essen,
der schlechter.
Der Patient habe die Schmerzen
in der Alp von zwei Monaten bis vier Kilogramm verloren.
Die Beschwerden seien von sehr.
Der Stärkauftritt der einmalige Hematomersis
mit einem Monat bestehender Zaurös aufgestoßen.
Er gleitet gewesen.
Der Patient hat seine Wärme geführt.
Seit zwei Wochen.
Ich weiß aus Bruch aus zwei Wochen,
sowie zweimalige Melena seit einer Woche.
Aufgetreten die vegetative Anemnese,
sei bis auf seit zwei Monaten bestehende Inapatens,
sowie seit gestern bestehende Schmerzbedingte Insomnie.
Auch der Patient klagt über seit drei, vier Wochen bestehende Pyrosis.
Anforkankungen und
Anforkrankungen, Allergien und Familienanamnese
seien nicht erkannt oder seien nicht auffällig.
Die Medikamentanamnese ergab die regelmäßigen
Antropole 40 Milligramm seit zwei Wochen.
Unregelmäßiger.
Eigentlich nimmt der Patient jeden Tag Pantoprolosol ein,
aber das sei
peglich unregelmäßiger gewesen.
Manchmal morgens, manchmal mittags, manchmal abends.
Aber der Patient habe jeden Tag Pantoprolosol eingenommen.
Und dabei nehme der Patient
bei Bedarf Paracetamol 500 Milligramm ein.
In Bezug auf die Genusmittel
rauf der Patient seit zehn Jahren,
sein 15-Sigaretten.
Er trink
eine Pilsche Bier,
so wie ab und zu ein Glas Wein,
nur am Wochenende.
Er gab keine Drogen zu konsumieren.
Der Patient, der Taxifahrer,
er arbeitet als Taxifahrer.
Der Patient ist gelösst.
Die Anamnese war schon so.
Und aufgrund von bisherigen Anamnesenangaben
gehe ich von Ulcus ventriculi
mit oberer nostral-intensine Pollutung aus.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen
Colicis toliteasis
und Akutes Abdomen in Betracht.
Als erstes würde ich den Patient
körperlich untersuchen.
Nach der Vitalparameterübertüfung
und der Körperpäler-Untersuchung
veranlasste ich eine Labordiagnostik,
inklusive Klinus-Brotbild,
die Entsinnungsparameter,
die Skerrpibesche,
und Colistasewerte,
die Gigatee, Bilurbine,
und die Entsinnungsparameter,
die ENR,
die Neerenwerte,
die Leberwerte,
so wie
Ja, ansonsten, ja, die Paz, die auch, oder amülase, so mal aus dem Bankras.
Dann, dann sollten ein ÖG den Erfolgen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Als Defrancels, wenn du sowas haben, gewinnt event?
Also, als erstes habe ich an einem Colitis, Colitis gedacht.
Ist Colitis eine gute Erkrankung?
Ja, also eigentlich, ja, es kann, also, obere genannten, also, das wird auch mit diesem Fall Auftreten der Beschwerden auftreten.
Das ist chronische Prozesse, aber auch es kann mit so starken Schmerzen auftreten,
weil auch die Patienten die Schmerzen mit Ausstraubung rechnen.
Und das also, tritt besonders beim Colostolythiasis als Beklarsymptome auf, deshalb...
Das heißt, sie wollen sagen, eine schuleste Stitis bei Lithiasis.
Das ist das, was sie sagen wollen, oder?
Colostolythiasis, also eigentlich Colostolythiasis.
Colostolythiasis, das heißt, man hat ein Stein in den Galenblase.
Also, Colostolythiasis besteht aus zwei Fächtchen, es kann auch Colitis sein,
dass die Steine sein, auch Colostolythiasis oder Galenwege sein.
Wenn es Galenblase vorliegt, wird man als Colostolythiasis, wenn es Colodocanal oder Galenwege vorliegt.
Das heißt, Colodocholythiasis, wenn es in den Galenwege liegt.
Aber wenn es in der Galenblase liegt, das ist Colostolythiasis.
Colostolythiasis, aber das ist keine akutes Ereignis, das ist nur einfach Stein in den Galenblase.
Und wenn sie über ein akutes Beschreiben, das heißt, das muss ein Entzündungprozess sein.
Das ist dann eine Schulestistitis, das heißt, den Entzündung den Galenblase durch Lithiasis, durch eine Stein.
Die Stein kann auch unterschiedlich sein.
Das heißt, das ist Colostolythiasis bei Lithiasis, sagt man am meisten.
Aber das ist Colodocholythiasis, dann ist das eine Entzündung von den Galenwege.
Durch den Stein-Ackern in den Galenwege.
Die Differenzierung, wissen Sie genau, dass auch so eine Prüfung beschreiben.
Manche Prüfer sind ganz spinnig und dann sagen, ja, was ist denn der Unterschied?
Sie haben nur Stein in Galenblase, jede Stein in Galenblase macht keine Probleme.
Sie können auch Stein in Galenblase haben, aber dann kommen Sie nicht mit dem Bauchschmelzen.
Aber das ist auch einfach eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Wenn Sie mit der Kute beschreiben, dann können Sie nicht sagen, nur Stein in Galenblase, dann muss es ein Entzündung sein.
Das wollte ich nur einfach bemerken, aber das ist nicht keine Krität.
Aber es ist nicht falsch, wenn Sie sagen, ich vermute, dass Stein in Galenblase ist, ja, vermuten Sie es gut.
Aber macht ein Problem, wenn das Problem wird, dann ist es eine Scholästistik, das ist bei Lithiasis, sagt man.
Weil das ist ein guter Problem, dann muss es eine Entzündung haben.
Ansonsten können Sie auch vielleicht einen Nierenstein haben, aber Sie haben keine Nierenkolleg.
Und sagt man, passieren hat ein Nierenstein.
Okay, ja, hat ein Nierenkolleg nicht.
Dann hat ein Stein, aber hat kein Nierenkolleg.
Solange dann keine Kolleg hat, das ist keine Differenzialdiagnose.
Sie haben das, aber es ist nicht als Differenzialdiagnose zu bezeichnen.
Als Diagnose können Sie es bescheiden.
Ja, die hat in der Stein in Galenblase, ja, kann man das sagen.
Das ist nicht falsch, genau, wenn man einen Süstern der Leber hat.
Ja, und der Nieren, der hat ein Süstern der Leber, aber hat eine Probleme damit.
Er hat eine friedliche Probleme, sagt man, nee, dann hat er ein einfach harmloses Süstern der Leber.
Solange man keine Probleme damit hat, das wird man als Diagnose bezeichnen, genau, aber nicht als Problem, als akutes Problem.
Okay?
Aber in diesem Fall hat der Patient gestern aufgetreten, dass die Stärke schmerzend ist, das ist akut,
aber seit zwei Monaten leidet der Patient an Bauchschmerzen.
Dann sagt man, es ist eine chronische Solicititis bei Litiasis, weil sie können auch Solicititis auch haben.
Mussten sie nicht Stein haben, sie haben auch eine Entzündung in Galenblase,
nicht durch den Stein, durch andere Rosaker.
Ja, muss nicht ein bisschen das Stein sein.
Das wollte ich einfach sagen, dass eine chirurgisches Fachdiagnose differenzierung,
da soll die Chirur, die kennen sich besser aus, aber natürlich man leidet auch im Verlauf,
wenn man als Entzünder arbeitet, von den Chiruren, die, wie die das beschreiben.
Okay, machen wir weiter.
Sie haben das Chiruristitis bei Litiasis, Chiruridocchi Litiasis, noch weiter.
Ja, als Differenzialdiagnosen.
Pancreatitis haben Sie erwähnt?
Ja, Pancreatitis auch, kann ich sagen.
Noch?
Denken. Also auch, ja, Myocardinfarkt vielleicht, aber das, ja, nicht so...
Typisch, ja.
Typisch, ja, aber ja, Bauchschmerzen, Epigacea Bauchschmerzen,
vielleicht kann es sein.
Ansonsten Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, Mesenterial infarkt vielleicht oder, ja...
Mesenterial, mesenterisches Infarkt, das ist er fast überhaupt nicht.
Ja, fast überhaupt nicht.
Das ist, das ist sehr, sehr akutes Problem, am meisten, wenn man Trombose hat
und Infarkt hat, Necrosa, das ist akut, da kann ich es so im Monat dauern.
Mit, also, deshtarkeschmerzen, also...
Aus Basis mit dem, wenn Sie das beschreiben haben, was noch das zu erwähnen ist,
eine Tumor.
Ah, Maginkarsmon, ja, ja, Maginkarsmon, oder vielleicht...
Also, sollen Sie nicht vergessen, ja, das ist der wichtigste.
Ja, das war meine...
Gedanke, ja, es ist auch eine Tumor, könnte auch sein.
Okay.
Aber ich habe die Anamnesis immer im Alkarson,
aber ich habe nicht Gedanke, ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe sie durcheinander überbracht, ne?
Es ist halt so.
Aber Sie sind ein richtiger Weg, Sie machen eine Magenspiegelung
und da, Mittelmagnenspiegelung, werden Sie genau sehen, was denn passiert, ja?
Und dann sehen Sie auch, wenn das Uncosus, Uncosus,
wenn das Tumus, Tumor, wenn das gar keiner von denen ist,
dann werden Sie dann natürlich auch einen Ultraschall machen müssen,
wegen der anderen Differenzialdiagnose,
Garland-Basa, Leber- und Garland-Gängur- und Punk-Herst,
das sollen Sie auch machen, noch dazu, aber ansonsten, ja.
Ja, also...
Ich glaube, das muss ausreichend sein, ja?
Ja, also wie zum Beispiel, der Pferd hat auf Steine,
kann man auch RCP durchführen, oder denken, auch vielleicht...
Nein, RCP, das ist auch...
versuchen Sie nicht in der Prüfung, viele Fachbegriff zu benutzen
im Sinne, wo Sie denn nicht erklären können, warum RCP.
Dass man fragt Sie, warum RCP, wenn Sie jetzt sagen...
Ich kann erklären, kein Problem.
Das ist einfach, also möchte ich sagen, ja.
Ja, sag mal, Sie...
wann ist die Indikation für RCP?
Indikation ist für RCP, ist also die...
nicht, also unverschämt, also das heißt, man kann an, wie zum Beispiel,
Garland-Wege auf Tretensteine benutzen,
RCP oder ein Tümer zum Entfernen auf Garland-Wege.
Ja.
Full Piccumi, meinst du denn?
Was?
Ja, nie Polpik.
Papillotok.
Papillotok, genau.
Papillotok, beide Papillotok kann man...
Aber bevor Sie eine RCP machen,
was machen Sie als erstes Untersuchung?
Also vor der Untersuchung...
Sie haben, Sie haben Verdacht auf einer Abgangstein,
oder Steinappgang, oder in Garlandgang,
Sie vermuten das klinisch, was machen Sie?
Als erstes sollten wir auf die Beschwerden...
Abklingen?
Ja, was machen Sie Diagnostik?
Da gibt es eine, da ist schon Tuorium-Gerupper.
Also, eine Domografie oder...
Reicht nicht aus.
MRT vielleicht oder...
Nein, MRCP macht man, das ist eine Standard.
Das ist eine Darstellung,
Mittel MRT, die Garland-Gänge,
von der Liebe bis zum Unten.
Und das kann man genau darstellen,
weil MRCP hat,
Sie haben jetzt vor Kurzem ein Patient,
wo ihn anders die MRCP bekommen hat,
durch Steinappgang in Garland-Gänge,
und danach hat er Pankratitis bekommen.
Das ist eine Pankratitis durch MRCP.
Der Mann war zwei Wochen auf Intensiv,
mit ne Kritisierenden Pankratitis.
Wenn Sie einfach so blenden,
kann man rein gehen, sagen Sie, das kann man machen.
Wenn man benötigt, das machen machen.
Aber wenn man nicht sicher ist, dann macht man MRCP.
Weil Sie versuchen, so weit wie möglich
diese Komplikation zu vermeiden.
Ansonsten, Sie haben eine große Komplikation mit der SCP,
kann man Sie nicht sagen, ich SCP jetzt einfach sofort zack.
Manche Gastronomologen machen das,
weil die sagen, wir sind genug gefahren,
wir gehen rein und nehmen alles raus, was es ist.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Manchmal kann man schon lebensbedrohlich werden.
Das war 40 Jahre alt, genau wie mir, sozusagen,
und war zwei Wochen auf Intensiv.
Ja, ja, aber natürlich denken wir nicht als erstes.
Vielleicht erstes, ESWL oder Medikamentustherapie.
Nein, nein, Diagnose, Sie haben voll recht.
Wenn Sie so etwas vertrachten, Sie müssen das machen,
aber da hat er einen Schritt.
Dann machen Sie den MRCP, und dann machen Sie den SCP.
Und manche Gastronomologen sagen,
wenn Sie gut ESCP machen, warum soll ich MRCP machen,
genau wie Sie, und sagen, ich gehe rein,
weil MRCP hat nur diagnostikte Maßnahmen,
oder ESCP, diagnostikte plus therapeutisch,
weil Sie sehen das und Sie nehmen es auch aus.
Aber wie zum Beispiel beide Sonografie, also wenn...
Ja, das ist schwierig, das ist nicht so einfach.
Auch wenn wir MRCP aufhören, dann MRCP, oder?
Ja, genau, unbedingt.
Wenn Sie diese Möglichkeit haben, würde ich sagen, MRCP, ja.
Und wenn der Chef sagt, ja, ich mache SCP, dann ist das okay.
Aber Verfahren, man sagt MRCP, ist besser,
erst mal zu gucken, ob man das hat,
wenn man das nicht hat, warum soll ich da rein gehen.
Nur wenn man fragliches Symptom hat, ja, wenn man nicht sieht,
dass es doch eine Steinabgang ist,
ob es eine andere Problemin die Gallengang ist,
dann braucht man eine MRCP.
Dann können Sie genau differenzieren, was das ist.
Ob das ESCP lohnt sich oder nicht,
dann mit MRCP, das können Sie entscheiden.
Aber wenn Sie das nicht wissen,
einfach blöden rein gehen,
und dann bringen Sie auch nichts raus,
das sei in der Komplikation von Tankretitis,
das ist denn nicht logisch, so zu sagen.
Aber wenn Sie sicher sind, dass es eine Steinabgang ist,
Sie sehen eine Stein in Gallenblase,
und bei Sinn hat eine Schulle-Docholatiasis symptomatisch,
sagen Sie, ich gehe, aber in diesem Fall
macht man auch das nicht.
Dann sagt man, er ist chirurgisch, der hat Steine in Gallenblase,
wenn Sie eigentlich den Chirurn geben, reingehen wir das raus.
Sie meinen in diesem Fall nicht,
aber bei der Symptomatische Beschwerdung,
die Steinbeimsonographik,
kann man direkt MRCP denken.
Wenn Sie eine typische Symptome haben,
dann können Sie drick denken.
Als Facharzt von Indera,
dürfen Sie aber nicht drick machen,
lassen Sie die Gastronomie das entscheiden.
Wenn Sie sagen, ich will das machen,
dann muss man nachher, nein,
die Gastronomie, die sich traut, das zu machen,
ist diejenige, die das entscheidet, zu sagen.
Weil wir als Facharzt müssen wir erst mal
Schritt-by-Schritt vorgehen,
damit die das unseres Betten nicht
ab und anders darstellen.
Sie machen es toll, sie sind sehr gut.
Was haben Sie durch die Studie in Türkei?
Ankeira University.